hello everyone how you soon hope you
guys are having a wonderful day today
we're here with another video and yeah
lately I've been doing a lot of videos
with many accounts and this is going to
be one of the same so I have a little
bit of money finally on this account
I've been working on actually trying to
gain GP now that I've stopped really
working at my hardcore Ironman so
basically what we're gonna go ahead and
do today I have a hundred fifty mil and
I got a little army of accounts back
here got four to be exact five in total
and I'm gonna go ahead and split up this
hundred fifty mil across all the
accounts so that'll allow 30 mil per
account and from there I think what
we're gonna go ahead and do is just do
one hour of merging from the grand
exchange I have no real margins bought
right now I don't really know what I
want to do I have ideas of items but I'm
gonna go ahead split out this money and
then we're gonna go ahead and make Bank
and there we go got all 30 mil dispersed
across the five accounts gonna go ahead
and get a timer now it will take a
second actually I mean the first 10
minutes I'm probably gonna have to spend
trying to find items so we're gonna have
to find some pretty quick and before we
go ahead and get on into it if you guys
are wondering how I am actually finding
my margins I use a site called GE
tracker their sponsor of mine it's an
absolutely great site that allows you to
pretty much sort different methods of
finding what the margins are for certain
items and then you can go from there to
check and see how good they are yourself
now I mean you can sort a lot of
different ways for the most part I'll be
doing the high-value method which will
allow me to do a lot of flips for low
margins but with five accounts is going
to be more where I'll want to be I'll
probably have one or two accounts focus
on some higher level stuff maybe you
know five to ten mill type items but for
the most part I'll be searching around
here alright so here we go going to go
ahead and start the timer now time to
get on into it what I want to do for the
most part is have a couple accounts
probably the top to focus on some more
higher priced items I guess so right now
Bandos got swords insta bought for five
three nine seven not absolutely that
great yeah no margin to see their
samurai gods swords however I saw have
about a 90 K margin so I'm gonna go
ahead and see what the exact prices are
on that as you guys can see dropped a
lot which is usually a good sign
whenever you're looking for a decent
flips 3 4 85 I think that's about a 70 K
margin right there now as far as crush
nest
I think crush nets are what I saw had a
really good margin a second ago yeah Oh
Mike 4 7 6 geez that is ridiculous
alright well I guess something that we
can go ahead and try to take it
now his bird's nest so bird's nest you
can actually crush but it seems as if
those are actually Gope no okay they
haven't gone up so I'm gonna go ahead
and put an offer for like two thousand
at this price that's going to work
really well if those are able early some
of those are able to buy so one thing I
said that I was going to do that I think
I'm gonna have to take more seriously is
the fact that not a lot of these higher
tier items have a lot of margin right
now anguish is pretty much have nothing
like 10k which is absolutely ridiculous
as you guys can see here though we have
3gp margins on battle staff so wow man I
absolutely hate my life right now okay
there we go oh thank god at least
something's going on so bird's nest got
a lot of them to actually be able to buy
which is good now I may crush them but
I'm probably just gonna take em monarda
because I mean if I'm crushing him
that's not really merging as much I also
could try to flip them up four four six
four nine which be a 300 K margin but I
don't think that they're going to
actually sell for that because not a lot
of people are going to want to crush
them for pretty much no profit now one
merch that I do like to do a lot is it
collect extense Evan hopefully that
hopefully they'll have somewhat of a
decent oh my thank you
okay so now we're gonna go ahead and
throw probably three thousand down there
another thing I think could be decent be
toughens armor sets of four six nine oh
let's see if we can get any margin on
that oh yeah 70 K margins there I'm
definitely happy with that I'm more than
willing to take that so we'll go ahead
and throw four and up they're going to
go ahead and throw up a 10k offer for
room darts as you guys can see the guns
and sets are actually selling which is
really nice but the rune darts we have a
17 GP margin on and if I can get 10k
that's a nice little bit of profit oh
boy so on top of that one thing that we
do have here is room darts are
apparently buying for 10 20 okay yeah I
knew I wasn't gonna get a whole lot of
those but really one thing I do always
want to do whenever I'm trying to merch
for money is just keep an offer in for
rune darts P they're actually worth more
if you clean them and so really you can
just make money off of you know using or
just one time using a cleaning cloth
onto some rune darts typically you don't
get them in that high of amounts though
so I'm just gonna go with 4000 as you
guys saw on the top left though Geffen's
armor sets have bought so we're gonna go
ahead and make 70k off all these should
be a 280 k profit in total so I found
another merch that seems to be doing
pretty well cabin time potions
I don't even know what they're selling
at 1812 or 1802 I'm just gonna put it in
for the Med price because that's where a
lot of people probably be selling at we
have one big Asian buying here on this
account that's got most of the money
capped out another three mils still to
spend over here we have some wines oh
okay well thank you we got some wines
the same rack buy those have around what
did I see earlier yeah 25 GP margin
that's fine I'll be able to sell those
for a little bit of profit up here on
this account we were able to get almost
10,000 rune darts to buy and we're
starting to try to sell them off for 17
GP prof which would be a hundred and
seventy K in total also getting some to
buy as poison I'm gonna go ahead and
once the hours done just clean them all
and see how much I can make off of that
and as far as birds nests really don't
know what to do I was able to get a 350
GP or I guess a 300 GP margin I'm just
selling the bird's nest but these never
really buy because there's no point and
really buying them so I'm really left
with two alternatives I can either just
go to Narda and sell them as crush nests
which I'm thinking about doing because
that's going to make us I guess the most
money theoretically if they don't sell
this way and yeah same Rock odds were
gonna go ahead and sell for their so
decided it probably wasn't best to
actually have to pick Asians buying one
on each account so went ahead and kind
of made my own margin on primordial one
thing I'll say is if you usually find
margins that seem to be too low and like
20k it's really worth the 20k risk just
to go ahead and buy and sell another one
to see we can find I personally just
found a 50k margin i'm primordial which
I'm more than happy to flip with
considering I can do that on one account
pretty much at all times so some margins
I've noticed up here in the top right is
basically you seeds you can make almost
3k by turning them into a plant pot or
by turning them into a sapling which I'm
more than willing to go ahead and try
and on top of that magic seeds
apparently are pretty good now over here
got a I think that's our first pair yeah
first pair on this account of Pagadian
to sell which is nice and over here we
have primordial is also going we've
already bought and sold one that we
needed to actually find the margin now
everything from here is going to be pure
profit which is really nice and while
I'm typing in that one we get another
Pagadian to buy what I'm gonna like so
much about these big Asians is they have
a 100k margin and I can pretty much flip
eight of them on each account that I
want so I mean potentially you know
depending on how quick they buy and sell
we could be balling out here anyways as
I was saying up here magic saplings also
have
about a 2k margin so definitely gonna go
ahead and utilize that if I can actually
closer to three-and-a-half K I was
looking at the wrong price but the thing
is we can only buy so many with this
which is kind of annoying it looks like
we can only buy about 15 that's kind of
one of the problems with the fact that
magic seeds are so expensive right now
now one thing that's pretty interesting
that I don't know if I really want to
get in on that bad Asgardian boots right
now they're all over the place they've
been going down a lot today which is why
their price is kind of volatile
yeah but 7.35 oh my gosh all right oh
that is a massive margin problem is I
don't know if I can recoup that I don't
know if anyone's gonna be selling more
Guardian boots but I sure hope so
because I just lost three hundred four
hundred and fifty K trying to find it
because I tried working with Bandos got
swords a little bit ago but now finally
they have a large and I've been trying
to yeah I've just been I bought and sold
a couple earlier trying to find if there
was one it seemed pretty sturdy but now
we see a 70k margin on Bandos guide
swords which is what I really want
because those things by itself really
quick alright here we go another set of
pegasi ins have sold so definitely made
200k in this account so far with them
looking to make a little bit more
primordial is kind of slowed down over
here Guardian boots still hoping for but
yeah really not a whole lot going on
except over here we just had a ton of
room darts sell so obviously made some
money off of that
another bgs all sold up here that's good
we just need to start to get them to
sell I guess that seems like a good
price to me and that also seems good now
as far as up here what oh there we go
another set of primordial but what I
think I'm going to do is the account
down here in the bottom right that I'm
using right now has a b7 farming so I'm
definitely going to have to get over
these magic seeds and use seeds of that
account
alright lot going on got another set of
big aging boots to buy hopefully they'll
sell a little quicker on top of that
Bandos godsword seems to be going pretty
well which is I'm definitely happy about
because these things are going to make
me a lot of money if they start flowing
decently well all the roon darts sold
and now just gonna go ahead and kind of
get in the zone ah there we go thank God
alright we got a pair of Guardian boots
to buy the buying part was really what I
was scared of I think they'll be able to
sell for around the price that I bought
them for I have no real worries about
that the buying of it though that was
definitely sketchy which means now I
think we should be in the positive as
far as this merch goes down here just
got another pair of prims to sell but my
was a little messed up so you couldn't
see that seems like forever but finally
the guffin sets of shower to sell I mean
I'm happy with that that the I mean it
it's definitely a good margin I'm
willing to take but it's just a matter
of whether or not they sell and it looks
like now they'll start to actually go
and there we go so we did get all of
these guns armor sets to sell and now
we're just waiting for some to buy as
far as the Bandos god swords they have
not continued to sell so I'm gonna go
ahead and drop the price of those all in
all should be able to sell I would
imagine at some point and then as for
the guns armor sets gonna go ahead and
wait for the rest of those to buy now
over here we are kind of working on
buying some seeds for the most part got
a lot of that going on got a decent
amount of magic and you see it's
probably about you know maybe close to
250 K profit in total now on the middle
screen currently working on buying some
primordial zyv done a lot of pegasi
emerges at this point probably I think
for all for pretty much 100 K but I
think I hit my primordial boot limit
over here on this account I've been
trying some margins on on top of that
been flipping primordial boots for about
40k they buy and sell relatively quickly
quickly so is worth it for me to
transfer that on over to here and down
here this is where we have another pair
of Guardian boots buy that is that's
what I like to see I really don't think
that there's any way I lose money on
this if anything the price of my sell
may go down a little bit but really
overall I'm not all too worried because
I think that they'll be definitely able
to sell above 7 mils so I'm happy with
that
and overall doing pretty good right now
so gonna continue on and see what all we
can do we do actually have some stuff
selling down here which is nice and yeah
I got some more rune darts buying over
here since I thought that that was
pretty good merch all right so now down
here working on putting all these seeds
into their respective plant pots and
then just using humidify on them to be
able to actually make them into saplings
really good way to make money you make
3k per one and takes literally seconds
just to be able to turn them into
saplings so alright and that is
terrifying now we have three Guardian
boots buff but none sold so this is
going to be kind of a moment of truth I
really don't know what they're buying or
selling at currently and I don't have a
lot of cash to say on most of my other
accounts actually be able to find out
what the price is alright so this is the
real moment of truth do I actually want
to insta Buy I'll just I'll try to insta
buy it for say seven point two ml okay
none insta bought for 7.2 ml that's
perfect
fine with me down here on this account
will be making 300k per one if we can
insta sell them for that so 7.2 I may as
well just try to buy another one if I
can make 300k off a Guardian boot it's
worth it to me oh my gosh down here in
the bottom right I got another pair to
buy I don't want all these pairs I want
to start selling them but I know no
one's selling them cuz they're scared
that the price is gonna go down and
there we go selling off some magic
saplings down here 1 9 1 700 as you guys
can see and then up here for each magic
sapling I actually paid 186 so that's a
5k profit per one 250 K and the bank
just off of a little bit of work on
magic seeds now that's not all for you
seeds we also have a little bit of
margin as well so I bought them up here
as you guys can see 479 K and I can sell
them for practically 82 so definitely
really nice also happy with that who
crushed his stuff Wesley hit me up boy
how much I just want to crush all these
can I do that it's 50 each oh it's only
50 each geez yeah that's perfectly fine
by me I thought it was a hundred and
fifty alright so if we go ahead and buy
crush but four seven seven eight oh my
god four seven seven eight we don't have
them up here anymore but we will out
that for around 45 even under 45 per one
so that's 300 K profit or more thank you
thank you thank you we finally got a
pair of Guardian boots to sell on who
would have guessed it I didn't know if
it was ever going to happen I was a
little nervous but at least now I got
some confirmation that's possible nice
and easy able to get all of the you
saplings that sell off so that is always
good to see and hopefully these pressure
Nets will start selling as you guys can
see someone probably just undercut me
there so I'm gonna go ahead and try to
go for 76 oh and maybe they'll sell for
that just as I ended off that last
recording got another pair of Guardian
boots to sell oh I'm so happy with that
obviously I'm just I'm happy to see that
those things weren't gonna going to
continue to go down because I was
definitely nervous about that really
they've dropped a lot so far already so
I wouldn't imagine that they'd be going
down any more which is why I was kind of
confident in buying them in the first
place oh my gosh we just got another
pair of Guardian boots to buy let's go
okay so I got another pair over here
hoping that they will be able to buy as
well but yeah definitely happy with that
another 300k coming in so someone just
sold another two three pairs of Guardian
boots it must be someone that was
stacked up on a few of them but
definitely happy to
go ahead and take all those at this
point I have six minutes left I don't
know how much more I can keep buying
because eventually I'm going to have to
sell these and I can't really into sell
them at the end of the hour because if I
do that I have no guarantees as to what
they're worth considering they're very
volatile in price I could easily just in
to sell them and lose a mil just end off
this video but what I think I'm going to
do is just cancel out all the offers
that I have in there's five minutes left
so I don't want to make any more money
and then sell the stuff afterwards so
I'm just gonna cancel all the offers
throwing a bunch of sell offers and then
we'll see what we can sell this all for
at the end on the plus side though did
have another pair of Guardian boots sell
down here and there we go liquidated all
the accounts right now 84 mil in my
inventory along with all these Guardian
boots obviously a lot of stuff to sell
and it's gonna take a little bit of time
so I'm gonna go ahead try to sell it all
and then probably hop back in about 20
minutes and see what it all sells for
also just want to say during that hour
as you guys can see roon darts Pia was
able by 2000 now I made 40 GP per one so
obviously a free 80k just from having a
GE offer and that I actually didn't even
have to focus on it also you know maybe
worth your time in there we go timer ran
out like to give a huge shout out to mr.
underrated though notice me from the
video shout out to you man thanks a lot
finally it all sold it took about half
an hour the Guardian boots worth of
really the only thing I was waiting on I
even had to downgrade their price a
couple times just by 10k to make sure
that I was actually able to get the
offers so yeah let's go ahead and see
what I can get for all this I do have to
sell off these astral runes because they
were part of the overall GP but let's go
ahead and collect 153 so we at least
made three mil that's so sick let's see
okay um how much okay 153 5 almost 3.5
milanesa actually really good I didn't I
didn't think I did nearly that well a
lot of my normal items weren't even
doing that good usually tortures
anguishes tormented bracelets they're
all things that I like to do as well but
I was kind of hoping for for this hour
but none of them had margins they were
actually like 10k or less for all of
them so I was a little disappointed that
when I actually started but 3.5 ml
granted obviously I'm using six accounts
but to be able to make 3.5 mill you know
that's a mill and a half more than
you're gonna get it's over and that's
even more than you're gonna get doing
raids and this is just merging so it's
kind of afk in a sense so hopefully you
guys enjoyed the video though if you
guys did make sure to leave a like if
there's anything you guys want to see
from me in the future comment that down
below and on top of that
you guys enjoy my content make sure to
subscribe to the channel but with that
said hopefully you guys have a wonderful
day and peace also here's a clip of me
freaking out because none of the jewelry
had any margins oh my god there's 2k
Martin's there's 17 K Marja than there's
10k margins on stupid
give me some decent margins